[Music]
hello I'm the Nostalgia I remember it so
you don't have to
apologies we're looking over pictures
with Tom Cruise's career now Tom Cruise
Tom Cruise's career and this is when I
jumped out of one building to another
Wow
this is when I jumped on a plane by
myself whatever you think of Tom Cruise
you have to admit his career is doing
pretty damn good granted there's a
slip-up here or there but Cruise has
proven he can be charming funny dramatic
and surprisingly kind of a badass one of
the reasons to see his films nowadays
doing several dangerous stunts driving
bad ass machines and usually hanging off
of something the guys like a male lair
Croft
even down to hating Jon Voight and that
shit is impressive really it is I can't
do that stuff there's just something
about it hey you want to see an
interview where somebody calls me
incredible her Tara time it's traffic
Thunder I really needed that nothing
let's just keep turning the pages this
way
I think someone's career went through an
awkward phase Oh topics honored to get
me out of any trouble that Mego got me
to in the first place okay is that you
jumping on Oprah's couch while wrestling
her no is that you as a samurai teaching
the Japanese the importance of their own
culture no is that you saying psychiatry
is a pseudoscience how did you get that
from a picture look I knew it your egos
more under control now but there was a
time where it was totally insane I was
young it's hard being constantly 35 then
what's this a picture of there's a face
it's nothing is that a leather jacket
and shades that's like what a fifth
grader thinks is cool oh I think I know
what it is oh no you don't oh yes I do
oh no you don't oh yes I do
oh no you don't know really I do okay
that's cruises career at the height of
his ego Mission Impossible two
Mission Impossible movies nowadays I've
gotten a reputation of being no good
they have good action good writing good
acting and ways to make awkward
superhero movies even more awkward but
people forget there was a time when they
weren't seen as bad the first film not
only confused people but have pissed off
a lot of fans of the show with a lame
portrayal of one of their weak
characters the third one underutilized
one of Hollywood's great actors and
turned in a snorefest with obvious plot
twists but by far the most hilariously
bad was Mission Impossible 2 this film
was directed by John Woo a filmmaker who
really wants you to know that a film was
directed by John Woo the days of a
secret team sneaking in together with
nail-biting suspense were gone and
instead replaced with Tom Cruise doing
90% of the work well everyone else
either types on the keyboard or bangs
and thank God you got the short straw
and big rains this was so much about
making Tom Cruise look good as opposed
to making a good movie that became
downright laughable so sit back and see
how over-the-top it can get this is
terminator know kung fu no James Bond no
Mission Impossible come on look at it
it's just like the show we open with the
sight is giving the most logical of
speeches resulting in the most radical
conclusions every search for a hero must
begin - something that every hero
requires a villain therefore we created
a monster kind of dummy a scientist
talks like this which major in comic
book hipster philosophy but these first
few seconds aren't nearly John Woo
enough whoa up that shit
wow you're quite the art house director
whoo now let's immediately cut the Tom
Cruise looking like that king of Kong
asshole
totally syncs up you keep staring at
that watch as if your life depended on
it done okay Ralph the bet we know this
isn't the real Tom Cruise because he's
wearing a turtleneck and in spite
villains villains always wear the
turtleneck there's an aisle for them and
target
here I thought the twist was he was
gonna be kevin kline in the only
disguise he thinks there is they take
the scientists samples and blow up the
plane leading to a perfect
representation of Tom Cruise climbing
his own sense of self-worth I do not
think you realize the gravity of your
situation okay so it's cool that he's
doing that stunned but unlike the other
films were ties in to the story and gets
you more into it what does the scene
have to do with anything
aside from Tom Cruise's erection sighs
no seriously there's a bug right there
on that mountain saying Ford talk about
being between a rock and a hard place
because Tom Cruise has a very big penis
what's up the credits by the way
sometimes the capital lies sometimes
they're lowercase sometimes they're half
and half oh maybe it's code that's how
you know we're in a spy film guys
I don't trust a movie less professional
than the writing on the kindergarten
lemonade stand but a helicopter comes
around stupidly points him out
no one's pointing at the other Tom
Cruise in this barren desert you dumbass
and Gizem is mission not sunglasses
because Tom Cruise thinks he looks cool
wearing sunglasses your mission should
you choose to accept it involves
recovery of a stolen item designated
chimera God don't you wish his mission
was told to him on a pair of sparkling
girl glasses that he'd be like I know I
don't wear enough to wear them if you
want the mission don't whine still manly
yes you are whoa this Samson glasses we
poetically transitioned to Spain with a
beautiful dancer spin in slow motion
revealing the majestic nature and
artistic elegance that only a Spanish
dancer would be able to submission
impossible right we see Katherine Zoe
Saldana Joan stealing a hidden treasure
when Tom Cruise sneaks in what are you
doing you think you're the only one who
can pick a look not just a pretty face
after all no no far less somebody walks
in though which means oh no we have to
hide in this hot tub together do you
mind if I'm on top
physically No Name wife hell yeah this
is varying distance
hey you put me here I just do as I'm
told the fact that you produced this
movie really indicates the exact
opposite the owner comes in though and
Cruz has to talk their way out of it it
does meet the case I figured did you
know what the circumstances I think we'd
recommend resetting the sensors to
respond to a lighter load and get a
slightly less silly jacket might I
recommend the horny Willy Wonka suit I
am currently being aroused in sir could
you work I was hoping we might work
together he asks her to join his team
but she refuses so they rip off the car
chase from Goldeneye because you know
James Bond is a cool spy who gets a lot
of pussy a Mission Impossible head Spock
in it which one do you think Cruise is
gonna go for will you just listen
Dianetics is a good boy dammit
[Music]
okay why is every shot in this a cologne
commercial cruise control when you want
to smell like you're trying too hard he
has a very big penis
they almost go off a cliff because
romantic and she agrees to accept his
mission I didn't mean it that way but
here we are
[Music]
Oh was there a mere next to her mission
impossible we do spy stuff eventually oh
if only we could keep all these women
from Tom Cruise's producing credit I
mean just Tom Cruise Tom Cruise himself
he's very secure very big penis oh thank
god here's someone to add some
credibility festivals a pain in the ass
that me except me I'm firing my way over
here oh oh you're American now sorry I
barged in on your vacation do you have
any idea what the hell he's talking
about you listening to me
oh yeah got an average American Joe why
don't you just sit over there next to
dr. strange house and every other Chris
O'Dowd performance we were just going to
talk about jazz and cowboys he's told
about the scientists being dead and that
is double Shawn was sent to him because
Cruz was on vacation
of course they explained Shawn went
rogue because it can't be a Mission
Impossible movie without an agent going
rogue I mean we could but then it'd be
like an episode of the show money and
cruise has to use his now current
girlfriend to infiltrate him as she was
once Shawn's ex-girlfriend I don't think
I can get her to do it you mean it'll be
difficult very well this is not mission
difficult mr. ant its mission impossible
oh I of course of course now it makes
sense you know the whole time I was
watching this movie saying why is it
called Mission Impossible like it was
confusing me I couldn't follow it but
now you clarified it thank you very much
not sure how that carries over into the
other movies like the explanation
doesn't really match to those were there
other thieves you had to convince to
join your team and that's why I got that
title but I now know it started here
even though it actually started here and
even before then it started here but you
clarified the title so there's no
confusion anyone want to see Halloween
so things are getting heavy
I guess because they're really amping up
the visual dramatic Ness
you you slow motion choir music and
things waving in the wind a lot I do not
think it means what you think it means
let's see these two talk like they've
been in a relationship for years even
though they just had a one-night stand
brought out by trying to kill each other
in cars and hot tub thievery somewhere
in the course of business this got
personal as well as physical to make you
feel any better if I didn't want you to
do this yeah much they'd feel better
well that was weird
let's talk happily about what we were
talking angrily about a second ago you
know sure we'll never be anything that's
suspicious at my bitch up saying hey
honey I'm home
what wouldn't make him suspicious I
don't know given as a spy you suck at
blending in I imagine that much she
pretends to be in prison in which Sean
breaks her out and only 35 minutes in do
we finally get a spy team this is like
doing an x-men movie for the first half
hour all weekends the kid who changes
channels by blinking a goddamn power I
really wish I had right now anything you
need me to get moving watch you sleeping
on your man look around look around
yeah yes it is first big introduction a
new jar jar binks meal but he muscle
cooler than the cruise so bubbles and
proto Simon Pig setup while wait shot in
the dark slow-mo dramatic music and
things blowing in the wind
you know I say visual storytelling is
good but you still have to tell a story
with your visuals
Wow you really thought that was a big
deal in June you know weirdly enough
mundane things are still mundane even if
you run them in slow-mo in fact they're
even more mundane could you have even
more time to realize how Monday they are
[Music]
[Applause]
our spy team watches what's going on
from a satellite
it's him Billy yeah so we got him we
don't know what we've got because we
don't know what he's got where he's got
it or if it's bigger than mine but
Moriarty here thinks that Shawn
shouldn't trust her what do you think
she's really young when she left you six
months ago
suggestive the hardly conclusive we to
just kiss already you have more sexual
tension than Max and Nev from catfish
yes that is possible don't worry this
won't be the first time we've ripped off
darkman in this I am game for it and
that's where I walk it's somebody cut
off my fingertips I'd be like bye I'm
gonna go join the dickholes they're
hunting you down true the pillow talk
was nice but this is just abuse Sean
takes Naya to a horse race where she
plans to meet up with crews how'd you do
oh there you are you're like Batman but
only better he sees that the dead
scientist has been working on what else
a deadly gas you know we're not short on
gasses that kill people why is this
always where man scientists go weave up
a faith under our own kitchen sinks go
outside the box they decide to visit a
CEO who seems to have a connection with
Shawn surprisingly in an onset away
George George
well bear look at today's paper is what
I do in this situation you gave me
tomorrow's edition this will not do well
that's going on Cruz apparently visits
nya
you're not Cruz he never allowed himself
to dress so average indeed it turns out
that Shawn who discovers she's a spy but
he has his own plans for her he's
critical if you do whatever
Ambrose asks you're gonna have to do
some weird sex stuff you know the bunny
from space gym he has a suit of her for
the sake of the mission you're gonna
have to be open-minded
the real Cruz is questioning the CEO as
the dead scientist you're still there
for all of it
I swear if I lose an eye before I do one
of those Potter films you are
genetically splicing together strains of
influenza and to create a cure for all
influences so here's an interesting
thing when you hear John woos mission
impossible - what's the first thing you
think of over-the-top kung fu
motorcycles shades and leather jackets
right but we're halfway through the
movie and surprisingly little has
happened
I dare even say it's kind of dull if
this was faceoff we'd be on cages third
scene chewing right now but this one
seems more concerned about having Tom
Cruise stand in front of sunsets when
that Sun just be a giant Nic Cage Oh
it's a John Woo film nobody will
question it
[Applause]
[Music]
so they figure house Shan has the cure
but not the disease and they both plan
to break into the CEOs building to get
it for themselves you'll never break
into by sight from the bottom where
security is heaviest hunt will prefer to
enter by sight somewhere from the top
where security is minimum and because he
thinks he looks cool hanging off a wires
so he knows exactly that with no backup
plan in case this guy saw him well that
was lucky and he goes to retrieve the
virus while Shawn enters from the other
entrance I'm exiting raspberry red and
entering lime green that seriously what
is with scientists and colored
lightbulbs but Shawn and his team
interrupt and Cruz has to fight them off
[Applause]
what's that a Tasmanian devil spin even
bubbles car gets infiltrated not sure
how a rearview mirror sees under a car
must be one of those high-tech spy
mirrors well hunt what did you call me
have you been fine ain't even ever
called
you know that was a hotspot humming -
for you you're running like an idiot
every 15 minutes let's now create hero
and villain chemistry an hour and twenty
minutes into the film but I saw them
walk in slow-mo that's all I needed
come on I hear you but yo she doesn't
belong here let her go okay it was bound
to work at some point get the thumb some
credit for the only intentional laughs
and the entire thing no I was in the
building
thank you
Naiya cleverly sticks herself with the
virus meaning they can't shoot her
helping crews escape was a good plan she
gets you out guarantees her safety a
while longer what was your plan flirting
with him in the hot tub he knows she has
to do now is simply escape with him
thanks again dick cheese you can hold
onto a mountain with your knees but not
a woman half your weight on a parachute
well great now she's in the hands of
that violent villain who believes
they're walking along some Pleasant
scenery okay it might be only one
feeling that Spy Kids is house-buying
everybody right now don't worry they
make up for it by having a secret
meeting with the CEO which is so heavily
guarded a guy climbing up the back and
get in you know for a film series called
Mission Impossible everything seemed
very possible you should just called a
mission wow this is stupid easy like
stupid easy crews breaks into the secret
hideout and there's my birds oh yeah
John Woo goes to John Kuh whenever the
situation presents itself hell even when
it doesn't present itself killing this
guy in his spare time both of you need
to put more effort into this if only
there was a symbolic visual that could
allow John woos ego and Tom Cruise's ego
to jerk each other off at the same time
oh never been ravaged by so much
insecurity I'm getting an STD just
looking at you oh don't worry by the way
the symbolism follows him around okay
it's funny enough seeing that dove fly
right in front of him during an
explosion like God and the devil climax
together but it kinda loses its grandeur
when he's just hiding in a corner with
it
oh boy Duffy are we gonna go on an
adventure today maybe we're gonna fight
some crime or solve a mystery or learn
how hamburgers are made I hope we've
learned how hamburgers are made kind of
like hamburgers I smell the everlasting
peace of Jesus Cruz we already get in a
fight leading to Cruz apparently being
defeated yet not saying a thing at all
yeah we're doing this dumb shit
[Music]
we're also many steps ahead were
re-enacting rocky at the top of those
steps no really doing it they're killing
Tom please
look absolutely play your big choir
music cuz we just lost a saint
he's been Tom crucified for our sins
I mean it's odd that all the advertising
shows him even more in the film fighting
and riding motorcycles like all the
advertising but that's just dedication
to their marketing fake-out Tom Cruise
knows how to keep us guessing
you ripped off darkman again film steals
from everything except Mission
Impossible thank God I had a makeup
chair in several hours to apply that
mask on him
time to put on my incredibly important
shades see you guys were all missing
because you're not wearing your shades
it's not just to look cool they're very
practical they are huh what's that
Cruz's narcissism isn't flammable
despite them clearly being flaming high
five okay so we partakes in let's be
honest pretty enjoyably stupid stunts
I'm awesome I'm awesome I'm awesome I'm
awesome I'm awesome I'm awesome I'm
okay the shades are bad enough but
Healy's tom
really so it's mono e mono is Shawn and
Cruz thank God they had that couple
minute talk to amp up the intense
rivalry that's been building we know
shit about your pastor you talk for two
minutes yeah this is earned
yes that was exactly as dumb as it
looked I think the only reason they
agreed to do this is because rocket
jumps and bike fencing weren't invented
yet in fact would you just pay anything
to see the miss by this point we really
should have bad Japanese dubbing mr.
cruise I can tell you were very upset
you have never seen me very upset power
is strong but mine is stronger and now I
have you right where I want but you
forget I am Tom Cruise and I produce
this mom good point let me just let you
get on top of me like I'm not even
trying to fight back because you are so
awesome I am so awesome more so awesome
Cruise has a chance to stab him and kill
him as I guess these random waves are
supposed to indicate I don't get it wait
I don't get it but he doesn't stab and
kill him that is not the Tom Cruise way
I much rather shoot that shit out of you
because that is the Tom Cruise way I
don't know I had a bird flying by in
still emotion so this all has to mean
something so the cure is given to Nia
and what are you still here
well mr. hunt as for Miss Hall in light
of her efforts a criminal record for
certainly be expunged I'm off to do a
transformer sequel rather than ever be
in any of these movies again think about
that Cruz meets up with Naya to prepare
to forget about her by movie three and
by far one of the strangest parks I
think I've ever seen why are they
throwing a football like that in fact
are they throwing a soccer ball too are
you gonna run a kite in the air with an
area this crowded are they juggling fire
juggles fire in a park yeah enjoy that
kid only two feet away one slip-up and
you'll be an extra from Total Recall no
no no no no this is awkward this is
strange it doesn't make any sense
I am only giving this to flaming doves
it's funny
when this film came out it was praised
for all the spy stuff but criticized for
cruises and Woo's ego boosting of
themselves but the interesting thing is
years later the spy stuff is pretty
boring in the cruise and woo stuff while
ridiculous is still wildly entertaining
these are too over-the-top artists who
love portraying themselves as more
important than they probably are but
when done this extreme it's kind of fun
weirdly enough though I could have used
a lot more of it as much of the film is
very slow and forgettable but people
still remember the over the top moments
enough I guess though usually with mixed
results it's definitely not Mission
Impossible it's just kind of an awkward
mess but you're in the right mood that
awkward mess can be laughably enjoyable
do you think you're tough making fun of
my career like that no no well yeah I'll
show you I'm gonna remind everyone how
amazing I am but hey myself on the hook
op they're finally gonna play tearing a
building no no Tom Cruise's career it
wasn't about the stunts at all yeah it
is
people didn't start liking you again
because you put yourself in danger I
totally did they like you because you
can be a good actor when your ego
doesn't get in the way it's a hundred
percent this does well when you look at
it's the stunts critic you're right
insolent stunts they're just so cool
really this there's no truth to what
you're saying before not okay I guess
we'll see if I survive my next flick
that'd be great okay what he was amazing
in Magnolia though my favorite is
honestly Rain Man oh how about in
collateral Oh ah usually but when you
really look at women just saw them
differently reason somebody say
something
stunts' stunts' stunts' stunts' stunts'
stunts' I've done this - your critic and
with a Publio
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
you
I look around
hey dub Walker here doing the charity
shot on this week we are doing the
Elizabeth Glaser pediatric AIDS
Foundation
this foundation seeks to prevent
pediatric HIV infection and eradicate
pediatric AIDS through research efficacy
and prevention slash treatment programs
they've emerged as the worldwide leader
in the fight against pediatric AIDS
working to draw top researchers to the
field as well as creating programs to
provide a full range of critically
needed prevention and treatment services
in developing countries they're also
training tomorrow's leaders in the fight
against HIV and AIDS and advocating for
children with policymakers their
programs offer hope for children and
families living with HIV and help create
a generation free of this awful disease
if you look at their site on their
YouTube channel you can see the tons of
good deeds and wonderful treatment they
offer to so many of those in need click
on the link and show your support for
those who give so many people so much
hope
[Music]
you